one of the things that happened in our
industry with streaming is that um the
consistency of work went down because
the holds remain the same um and what
that me for your audience that means
that the length of your contract you
basically are under contract from a
certain date to a certain date and they
have any time within that date to pick
you up for the next season um they
usually wait till the last minute they
prevent you from doing other stuff and
the problem is those those holds are
insanely long they're like 12 13 16
months from your last day on set not
from the beginning from your last day on
set and the problem is you're doing
Eight Episodes now you're not doing 22
anymore right so you can't rely on a big
paycheck really no and it's it's your
time on hold is so much longer now and
you know they can say we're not
preventing you from getting work but
other companies won't touch you with a
10-ft pole if they know you're under
contract with someone else so there's a
there's a lot of downtime one of the
things is the residuals actors used to
be able to support themselves off
residuals during those insane long holds
that doesn't exist anymore so so you
know um they pay me very well and and
well enough for sure um but I would love
to have uh more episodes or shorter hold
times for sure and not just with that
company with any company yeah I mean
look these the roles that we get you
know in this industry we don't know how
long they're going to last we don't know
if they're going to last a season or get
cut short not do a whole season or two
seasons or whatever it is so all this
time that you work on you make what
seems like a significant amount of money
yeah some more significant than
others uh you know you don't know what's
next though and most the time people
have jobs they work nine to- five jobs
or whatever they're doing they know they
have work tomorrow next week as far as
their they have their job for the most
part
but actors it's a again aine yeah you're
just well this Project's over I got to
go get another job so you're always
looking for another job yeah and so it's
uh you know yeah it's it is like that
and it's a little um terrifying when you
have a family as well because our
insurance is is completely tied our
health insurance is completely tied to
our the amount of money we make and if
you're on hold and you start to go well
crap you know yeah everyone's like you
know and people and it's not it's not
them being rude it's not anything but
people just don't understand the
industry they're like why don't you work
for Marvel why don't you go work for
blah blah blah and I'm like I'm like
guys they haven't called me don't you
think I would love to have a job right
now no one's called my friends do the
same thing but it's usually about women
why don't you date Nicole Kidman man
like well well she's dating a rockstar
and I don't know her well can't you meet
her
I mean shut just shut up that's what I
want to say that's what I say to my
friends they think you know hey man we
want to know you're it's yeah because
only because they don't get it they
don't know the world that we live in
that's kind of like it's not all that
glamorous a lot of times most times it's
not um it could be great but uh it's and
it's a small world too isn't it it feels
very small it's very small it's it is
very small and it's very like um um uh
you know this is just really it's a
really tiny business everybody knows
everybody to a certain extent everybody
is you know known someone who's worked
with someone that that's worked with
someone and and you get to a certain
point and you're like well if the if the
phone's not ringing it's it's just
because there's nothing right for me
right now